es gibt Dinge die werden sich auch über
den Marktregeln das sind so Dinge die
jetzt nicht zu einer gesellschaftlichen
Grundversorgung zählen und im Bereich
Flugindustrie das hat auch Frau hat man
gerade angesprochenen riesige
Subventionen wenn man einmal tatsächlich
die Kosten von was kostet fliegen
tatsächlich einen Preis dann ist klar
man wird nicht mehr für 9 oder 1900 auch
nicht 29 Euro nach Mallorca fliegen
können und es ist auch okay wir haben
alle in der corona-pandemie plötzlich
erlebt oh Leute finden wandern wieder
ganz toll weil das ist auch tatsächlich
ganz schön und ich glaube da werden wir
eine Verschiebung erleben qualitative
Verschiebung wir brauchen aber natürlich
gerade wenn wir uns ankommen anschauen
dass viele der Vorschläge wie können wir
in den marktwirtschaftlichen System die
Klimakrise einnehmen natürlich über
Marktmechanismen gehen dass wir sagen
wir besteuern CO2 es gibt einen Preis
für CO2 auch für andere Treibhausgase
dann müssen wir auch Einkommen gerechter
verteilen dann kann es nicht sein dass
es Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
gibt die unter der Armutsgrenze leben
die ähm oder die Arme gefährdet sind das
kann nicht sein sondern da müssen wir
dann auch wieder staatlich Eingreifen
das Glas es gibt Existenz für alle
Gesellschaft